I find it funny when I read in the
comments that people are always saying
it's like I'm on a date with - hey guys
so we're in the car right now as you can
see we're heading to this place called
the happy place it's like this art
installation type of place where it's
like Instagram friendly so we're gonna
be heading there now as of now I think
weren't G over there we might run into
them we might not so today we have a few
things planned for us we are trying to
get new cell phones because our phones
are really bad that's why I've kind of
been in my a on social media because my
phone keeps turning on and off on me
it's been very difficult to do anything
on my phone recently oh okay Gio got me
an Apple watch for my birthday can you
guys believe that I am such a lucky
Briton she actually got me an Apple
watch so I've been trying to use it but
my phone keeps crashing on me so it's
affecting the Apple watch as well so I
really need to get a new phone because
of that reason but Gio is such an
amazing friend thank you so much - I
love love love the Apple watch and it's
so funny cuz she got it for me on my
birthday right my wonderful husband here
surprised me with a beautiful dinner in
downtown LA it was like the most
gorgeous view ever JK crew was there and
it was
it was a really nice dinner and so
before the dinner began Gio gave me my
birthday present she was like open it
open it she was so excited and so I
opened it I was like what you got me an
Apple watch that's like you're so
generous to do like I just couldn't
believe it so the whole dinner
it just kept like playing with they
trying to set it up geo upstaged by
dinner it was like one of those for
dollar sign places I go to you like a
nice view of downtown like where I got
like the 35th floor and you didn't look
up at all every time you looked over at
me that's when I was looking at the what
but now I was really enjoying the
beautiful restaurant even part we have
captioned usually he was like I saw like
it was my friend
I think everyone got to enjoy the
beautiful view oh and then Julia she's
so sweet she also got me a birthday
present which was a whole bunch of
makeup cuz she saw my daily makeup
routine video and she she noticed that
even the new highlighter a blush
eyeshadow palettes and the best thing of
all she got me the Anastasia brow gel II
all of you guys were suggesting so I'm
using it right now and it's been amazing
I love you guys were right this product
is awesome so thank you for that
suggestion and thank you so much xx
effort getting it for me for my birthday
that was so sweet by the time I opened
it we got home and I was like Casey like
that's so sweet she's so thoughtful she
actually watches our videos so yeah that
was a great birthday and then thank you
guys also for all the birthday wishes I
was really sweet but yeah I think we're
pulling up now
to the happy place so we'll see you guys
in a bit
we're still looking at your iPhone and I
know that was texting Geo
we just saw her pass by there trying to
find parking okay look who's here hello
water please that Timothy water have a
palate happy people happy people for a
happy place good morning
my lane just oh it you made it you're
inside welcome well it's so good
[Music]
I think we should not worry we gotta be
happy so we're gonna split up for India
so you get to check out March gos
perspective of this place up there
it's like it's like a dimensional
transport ation oh ho are you ready yeah
we should take photos go oh wait cool
are they different flavors few months
ago and never posted any photos oh maybe
I should
[Music]
and these more like
oh it's more uh but you did them oh my
god there's me like let me try let me
try
how do we do this we wrap ourselves too
we're so silly there's like a trailer
M&M
[Music]
happier now I do this place is making me
feel happy it's all except these lovely
colorful
like
we can't get away we're all like stuck
in the same kind of
so we can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
more sugar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and they call it a for ik
[Applause]
oh man I look scary people lighting your
brows create like the creepiest shadow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Martin do you have to leave because they
had a meeting and plus we were trying to
be separated since they were also
vlogging really we don't let the same
vlog there was like the same content so
I was like you guys do you will do us
and so we is funny cuz we kept trying to
like get away from them but we kept
bumping into them yes did you like the
happy I feel a lot happier now it's like
a massage for your soul though that's
pretty much what it is it's like massage
for your eyes massage for your taste
buds and a massage for your soul and you
just feel happy anyways now we are at
CBS and we are gonna take our pictures
cuz we need new passport photos to get
new passports and then the reason why
we're updating our passports is because
one they're about to expire - we need
new passports because we're gonna be
doing a lot of traveling in the next
couple of years because we have a bucket
list because of something that we
haven't told you guys but you guys know
how everyone around us is having kids
you guys have been asking for a baby tan
for a while but we just got married I
feel the pressure guys and I'm like he's
ready his parents are ready all of our
friends are just ready to see us head
shoulders our heads right now everyone
okay go from here found the only one bet
on things like I'm just like no guys I
want to be a little selfish still like I
just grasped adulthood and like the
freedom of adulthood because now Isaac's
old enough to take care and so so that's
that's been my whole thing right now
it's like I I'm not ready for another
one and starting all over and like all
because I know the harsh realities of
having a kid so that's right get tied
down I'm like I'm not ready for that I
started analyzing myself okay what's the
reason why you're not ready Tiffany and
then I start talking myself and I was
like okay well I think I'm not ready
because I feel like the one thing in
life that I feel like I really haven't
felt like I've accomplished is traveling
and that's like the number one passion
in my life like that's the thing that
really truly gets me excited and I can
look forward to the future with our
travels
I was talking to Casey and I'm like okay
you know what we're not gonna have any
more kids until I get to see the world I
want to see the world before I bring in
any anyone else into this world so I
created like this travel bucket list and
then we're calling it the pregnancy
bucket list and so once we get to travel
to all these places and I get to satisfy
that like travel bug in me then that's
when we can talk about having kids so
that's the reason why we need to update
our password because we're gearing up
for next couple years of travel so I'm
really excited because I get to I get to
see the world and then he gets to look
forward to having a kid because that's
the one thing you're really excited to
see the world I have a kid actor yun
travel yeah you have a kid more than
Charlie because I see Bart having the
one I see and having one you know and
then like and I say okay I'm gonna have
one Friday case they're pregnant right
now yeah so it's like I'm just excited
to join that train because all my
friends are in that conversation and be
a dad with an infant and toddler you
know cuz Isaac's past that now and we're
entering like teenage talks now we're in
tween here between now we're hitting the
tween years he's starting like girls I
think actually maturing a lot faster
than what I remember I was like I feel
like this generation is growing up way
faster than we did but yeah
so that's that's the plan now you guys
are in on it
the pregnancy bucket list that's what
we're trying to accomplish comment below
where do you think we should go
oh yeah where do you guys think we
should go our anniversary's coming up in
May so even though we got married like
we had our wedding in July we're not
really celebrating that as our
anniversary we're gonna stick to May
19th
as our anniversary because that is the
day that we legally got married here in
LA last year so our one-year wedding
anniversary is coming up and so we were
planning on doing a trip to knock out
some of these countries that we're
trying to go to and so I don't know what
do you guys think maybe you guys can
like help us out in a decision where we
should go in May for our trip maybe you
guys can give us some suggestions we'll
check out the comments and see what we
end up deciding on you guys can help us
decide because we really don't know what
to do right now I just want to see the
world I have this wanderlust and me that
I just need to satisfy I wanted to see
the worst but anyways we're gonna go
inside right now and go take our
passport photos we'll see you soon
bringing back
all right so CBS didn't work out their
camera I guess wasn't working so we
ended up going to Walgreens and what do
you guys think here's my passport photo
and then here's Casey's passport photos
we'll see how they turn out on the
actual passports cuz you know once you
get your passports the lines kind of
like make your face look weird sometimes
my last passport I had these clear
braces on so in the photo it looks like
I have like teeth coming out it was
really weird
cuz of the blue lines to kind of like
warped everything's I don't know we'll
see how these come out how important is
it to you to have IDs and passports
things like that and to have that photo
be like really presentable this to me is
not I am a vinyl top person which I need
a cell like vanity like then how do you
say it as a person of aim babe am i yeah
you're vain it's okay I guess I'm vain I
want to look good uh who doesn't I guess
you don't but I want to look good for my
stuff that's what I was just telling
Casey that this photo I kind of didn't
like the lighting I'll put in this line
so you see like the lighting around my
eyes and my mouth and my neck is just
really dark it kind of almost makes me
look kind of like a skeleton or
something I don't know it's really dark
yeah I didn't even know that we had to
put our hair up now for these passport
photos cuz the guy that took our photos
the name was will shout us to will cuz
he also watches our vlog so thank you he
was like I know you guys so he was
really nice he let me borrow his
scrunchies I could put my hair up cuz I
didn't have winds up thank you well so
now we are gonna go get our new phones
finally I'm like so dying for them I
need my new phone people keep texting me
and I'm in the middle of trying to write
the text and my phone turns off it's so
frustrating so we're gonna go get new
phones and get me worried sick now they
don't text me back into that timely
manner anymore well I see the phone
break on your ass yeah Oh show them your
hand so I was speaking of vanity like in
my hands
yes while we were waiting for our photos
I was shopping a bit and my nails done I
was checking out nail colors I wasn't
trying to do your nails like fully I was
just
think of swatches that's what it's
called like I was doing like some swatch
oh yeah I should wear the swatches now
like how you're walking at those ended
I'm going with this nail polish I know
we'll try it out it's his pinky that's
what this color was oh yeah so I'm also
changing my service provider carrier the
phone carrier person I don't know what
they call it I've got to hear this story
all right so I've had a tea since I've
had a cell phone like I've always had
AT&T and so I got grandfathered into
their unlimited plan for I don't know
like a cheaper plan I don't know I got
grandfathered into something because
I've been a longtime customer and then
after I got grandfathered into that
program I because I was having
connection issues with a teen teen I was
asking around like oh you know what
service do you guys have like all my
friends so Bart Gio and Joe all three of
them whenever I didn't have service they
had service so I asked them what do you
guys have and they said Sprint and so I
asked them like are you guys happy with
first they're like yeah we love Sprint's
Prince awesome this is a few years back
so apparently Sprint have gotten
progressively worse just took a nosedive
it did it took a major nosedive because
as soon as I I switched over to Sprint
I can't do anything on my phone I get no
service ever and it's I've thrown my
phone so many times like maybe that's
why it keeps turning off on me because
it's just so frustrating having Sprint I
never have service I can't even text
anybody if someone a phone call like it
doesn't let me multitask like that so I
hate sprint with all my Luckies like I
hate sprint so much and so switching
over from AT&T to Sprint has been my
biggest regret now that we're gonna get
new phones I'm gonna go back to AT&T
which I should have never left because I
ended up losing that grandfather thing
and then Casey and I were gonna have our
own family plan oh yeah I'm finally
growing up I'm becoming a big boy he's
been with his parents this whole time
this whole time I've been on my family
plan with the birds
yes oh now we're finally gonna have our
own family plan it's a rite of passage
when you can have your own phone plan
with their wife your finally cutting the
umbilical cord
yes anyways we're gonna go do that now
all right guys so we are in the middle
of getting our new phones but apparently
it's a very long process we're doing
we're doing somewhat like complicated
stuff I guess with our phone lines so
the guy told us like oh won't you guys
just go out and eat committee overheard
that we're hungry so all right we're
gonna go eat while we wait we came to
this sushi spot really cute we're about
to open our brand-new fun check this out
we got the iPhone 10 that's my baby you
jealous
put a fingerprint on the plastic part of
the wrapping it would you got it to get
out the age what do you mean why do you
say like that it's so good bones it
ain't the ex oh we can share so the
reason why I got the 10 and he got the 8
was because a TMZ has this like I won't
get one for you deal right now but it
doesn't apply for a 210 it only applies
for like two eight four one ten one
eight and in sincere he's not even on
that into Texas hours so honestly
getting honestly getting the ten on you
would be away I'm not even a tech person
either but and after this we gotta go
pick up Isaac
we get to show him our new
he's gonna be jealous because a why
didn't I get a phone to it like no
you're you're only nine you don't need a
[ __ ] watch one bad dog yeah he's gonna
have to wait
[Music]